play watch listen is officially
supported by patreon patreon helps us
pay artists do more fun creative stuff
and that lets me give you ad free
versions of the show so if you want to
support play watch listen check out the
link in the description so my first my
first movie was a shitty movie called
striking range
with uh one lou diamond phillips
did you have any interesting stories
with him
did you used to smoke i used to smoke so
i saw him
so i did i got an audition for i'm sure
i've told this story but [ __ ] it i don't
care um i i got an audition for as we
established earlier off camera unrelated
to this many good things started by
going [ __ ] it and just your story
caution
now we have content
um i i got an audition for this western
and then
my agent called and said they want you
in albuquerque new mexico on wednesday
this is like monday or something
and uh
for a callback i was like they're gonna
fly me out to new mexico she goes oh no
no no you have to go on your own dime
and i did not have enough money in my
account to cover that flight
so at the time i was working at this
church beau chancey was was my boss and
he was like i got you and so he paid for
my flight
and i flew out to new mexico and i went
in for my audition and
they were like pulling the
uh uh
pulling the trigger on people like right
there they're like get this person into
wardrobe right now and so i was waiting
for my chance for them to go
do you want me to get in the wardrobe
they're like no thank you very much
and so i was like okay
and like a week later i get a call from
my agent she goes hey they just have one
question
um there's it's between you and another
guy in new york and they want to know
can you ride a horse
are you guys already recording oh yeah
we're recording we're in it this is it
this is the show we're in there i was
like he said can you ride a horse and i
went this is good content this is good
for things we need to make sure this is
how we got this was i jokingly asked
troy if he could ride a horse and he
started telling the story and i said did
i not say troy this is content
can you ride a horse i was like ma'am
i'm from texas
what do you
think i apologize
that's not a yes so technically i didn't
lie because technically i could not ride
a horse i've never been a horse
in my entire life but i didn't answer i
just let
the lingering doubt i let her fill in
the gaps uh so it's one of my i love
this story i feel like you haven't told
this here i mean i tell you like it's in
every podcast this is exclusive new
content we're doing it yeah so i i get i
get on and i took one class before i had
a flag i get together like you need to
be out in new mexico and like two weeks
whatever so took one writing class
and so i'm i'm out on set questions
writing classes what you actually took
it was not useful for the course yeah
there was no horses i was like this is
interesting
and so i i get out there and there's
like it's everybody it's it's the entire
cast so it's like carl urban steve's on
ryan merriman all these guys
and everybody's up on their horse and
everybody feels incredibly comfortable
and then there's me
and
one of the vaqueros the one of the
wranglers came up to me is named dutch
and he looks at me and leans across
here
checks out yeah
i could like pan up from the saddlebags
to his face and it was the same
consistency it was just like this guy
had been out in the sun his entire life
and he looks at me and he goes how good
of a writer are you
and i went um you know he goes don't
[ __ ] lie to me because we're gonna
find out in about 10 seconds
and i said i could i could use some help
he goes okay
they had me on old mexico that was the
name of my horse and i found out that
why they called him old mexico is
because he had a lot of gas
and old mexico wanted to be at the front
of the line so when we're walking
everything's fine but the second that we
all kicked into a little bit of a lope
as tony cobb our stunt coordinator said
my horse goes taking off and i'm just
flopping around trying to hold on to it
and everybody had to stop and i go oh
hold on
and this guy reed steele that was his
name reed steele wow
clearly a porn star
or a superhero yeah this isn't my day
job by the way
i make films
so
he uh he goes i'm going to take troy off
to the side and i went to i went to
remedial cowboy camp and learned how to
ride a pony
and i thought that i was fired and i
came back and everyone was proud of me
and i i rode a horse for for the movie
and i fell in love with with riding
horses and i want to get traveler on a
horse this is typically around four is
the age where they they'll start you
know teaching kids here's the problem
you teach kids to like horses they will
need you to buy them one i was a
horoscope expensive hobby oh man and uh
if you if you if you if you get your kid
into horses
the asking for a horse won't end until
about 15.
but you like
you like competed right did you do like
hunter jumper and dressage and [ __ ] like
no um we did cattle herding at like a
local oh you were like like western
style yeah i was sick oh [ __ ] yeah we'd
like camp out because sometimes it would
take two days
it was awesome it's really cool but uh i
never got the horse because my family
didn't have any money you grew up in the
guy pierce movies that guy pierce makes
back when he goes back to australia to
do uh helps that's basically blasphemous
to bring up the australian people of
that movie
i think there's like 10 movies that fit
the bill i just described that
like australian westerns
it's true yeah don't don't get your kid
into horses that's all i'm saying i've
missed you all i have i've missed you as
well yeah we've had earlier it was like
ages since we spoke we've had a bit of a
uh a rhythm uh with this show how was
your uh prom austin
my prom i got a very lovely corsage
we did some staircase photos
you know what i meant
yeah uh it was
uh [ __ ] amazing i appreciate
the accommodation
the context of whatever what's up i'm
meeting so much
yeah i'll just buy time for troy here
you were at the proms weren't you which
if anyone anyone brits watching that's a
big [ __ ] deal like that's a genuinely
massive cultural thing oh is it
yeah the proms is a thing that's put on
by the bbc
um and it's a
like several week long
festival at royal albert hall
um
which is one of the one of the main
concert venues in london for like big
shows
and it's been going for i don't remember
when it first started but it's this was
i think it might be a century like dec
definitely decades like the proms have
been around as long as
they've like institution yeah
yeah it's it's
and one of the things that's cool about
it is um it's supposed to be a kind of
um
you know uh
first off they put it on tv so it's they
broadcast all the concerts so it's meant
to reach the widest possible audience
they also
the royal albert hall has big
wrap-around seats and a floor seating
and they get rid of all the floor
seating and make it standing room and do
really low cost tickets so people can
bring their families people can you know
it's really
it's meant to encourage like if you've
never been to any kind of classical
music or anything like that this is the
one to go to that's kind of the vibe of
128 years
128 years
that's what i'm saying it's like that is
that's incredible achievement like the
queen's one of the shows
like i mean he's my first royal albert
hall won't have existed much longer than
that because obviously it's named after
albert who's prince albert in a can
that's actually
so victorious so literally
from the victorian era because he was
married to us so like it's got this
it's like yeah that's a factor in the
era
victoria celebrating
i think it's celebrating 150 years this
year
uh how is it really old and oh
yeah so it's only started like a couple
of decades after it opened that's
amazing jesus that's incredible but yeah
no it's a massive british institution
this is really impressive yeah this
would be like like austin saying like
yeah they played a bit of journey at the
super bowl it's no big deal um
it's a similar yeah the thing that was
the thing that was really exciting was
that you know the the proms has tended
to be uh you know a kind of who's who in
the classical music world you know
you'll have your yo-yo ma types who come
and perform because it's it's like every
day for weeks
you got your yo-yo ma's you got your
babies
yeah
so they um announced a few months ago
that they were going to be doing the
first ever video game music show at the
proms
and i saw the announcement publicly like
everybody else so i just assumed
that whatever like by the time they
announce things it's kind of like the
video game industry by the time they
announce it most of the decisions will
have been made about
all the goings on under the hood and
behind the scenes
to my surprise
like a month or two after they announced
it the they reached out to me um
and said hey we'd love to include
journey on the show do you have
uh sheet music that you could send our
way
and um
so i have
over the last 10 years since journey
came out i have um sheet music that was
made for like standard orchestra
performance because a full orchestra can
be as few as 40 or 50 people and still
kind of qualify for full orchestra or it
can be this gargantuan like mahler
orchestra of 120 people or more
and but a normal orchestra like if the
you know if if if the you know
like
trying to think of a of a good example
you know if the if the sacramento
symphony were to reach out and say we're
doing a show do you have sheet music we
could take a look at for our show
they're probably not going to be putting
on some gargantuan spectacle it's going
to be like a normal kind of potato
sheets that you would send based on the
size of the orchestra yeah wow you have
to make different versions because if
you if you if you're if your sheet music
is calling for instruments that they
won't be using
then obviously something's got to be
changed and there's some kind of
friction involved in that and so
years ago i prepared a kind of like here
is the generic 60-ish piece orchestra
you could play it with more people
theoretically but you know like more if
you know strings is where you end up
with the majority of your of your
compliment anyway and more strings is
pretty much always welcome but
what we would refer to it as wins by two
which means like two flutes two elbows
two clarinets two bassoons and that
usually is a couple of great chicago
record by the way wins by two
um
and then four french horns three
trumpets three trombones one tuba that's
like that that's the part that scales
the most aggressively why is it always
welcome to have more strings
uh
because strings balance like a hive mind
and so
if you have 14 first violins or if you
have 18 first violins you know your
orchestra has moved by four people
that's a big difference from
four extra trumpets like if you went
from three to seven trumpets that would
be a massive because they're so loud
individual violins we always chill
they're really not very loud okay so
that's why it's all about like a 60
piece orchestra 45 of those are going to
be the strings gotcha and so you can
picture it when you picture an orchestra
it's all those violets and then the back
would be you know two flutes two of them
so anyway
the standard kind of generic symphony
orchestra what we call wins by two and
that also means any weird like unusual
instruments they they might do what we
call standard doublings which means the
second flute can also play piccolo the
second oboe would play english horn the
second clarinet would play bass clarinet
and maybe the second bassoon would play
contrabass soon but that's it well so i
i made like a conservative orchestration
of journey years ago because i was
getting asked by like normal orchestras
that were not doing big gala events but
just having like a normal show
if they could have some of the sheet
music and so for example like
um
uh when you need like journey calls for
cello solos that were played by tina guo
in the in the original recording
if
i i wrote the score so that like the
first chair cello can play those solos
and then kind of join the rest of the
section so they don't have to hire an
additional
musician for this like it's those kinds
of accommodations yeah it all sounds
very nitty-gritty but if you don't do it
super interesting they can't perform it
they literally will go well this is
going to price us out so
i sent them my generic like well here's
the standard suite that people tend to
do which is nascents into apotheosis
into i was born for this i was born for
this requires a singer it's the sort of
the song at the end of the it plays over
the ending credits of the game
so they were like they looked at it and
they went
you know this is the pro it was so funny
to get this very polite per email from
the person it was the royal philharmonic
orchestra playing and they sent me this
email that would go
um
this is all well and good we're gonna
have a bigger orchestra
than this
do you happen to have like
other charts and it was like well i just
so happened to have released
a 10th anniversary edition that was
recorded with a 95 piece orchestra how
about you take a look at this um but
then the funny thing was they said um we
won't have any singers though so i said
well how about we do
the middle bit with it's called road of
trials that's the surfing section which
is a very energetic and fun kind of
middle
portion and so i sent them that from
this
you know traveler symphony
um
and uh and so that's what they did it
ended up being the largest section of
the whole show it was like most of the
most of the pieces were like here's a
five minute you know like zelda or
whatever and they did like over 15
minutes from journey
um five minutes zelda or whatever
you know
move along i want to point out something
it was they just played
i don't want to sound cavalier about it
because it was like i flew myself to
london for 24 hours just to go to the
show because it was such a bucket list
like everyone kept going how long you
been in town and i i was like i've been
in town for three hours one day yeah
and like literally landed you know
noonish before the show and was out
noonish the following day may i point
something out for all for all of our
yesterday whether you be on youtube
or spotify or wherever you consume your
podcast not if you're on itunes please
switch off if you're on itunes for a
moment at the time at this time if
you're listening on itunes
flip that was an austin wintry story
that was uninterrupted
technically still talking until you
interrupted him at the end no he
finished a story and had a great button
narratively that was the end of it and i
i specifically waited
um i also
as a serious follower with with what's
happening in the news right now um i'm i
want to know
um
specifically from you alana where
the [ __ ] is the chicken nugget because
it's it's gone and it's kind of throwing
me off what's happening in the news
the chicken nugget
is not that i mean it'd be off camera
anyway but actually it is in another
room
no it's always on camera
i never moved the camera adjusted her
camera i understand it's probably
something a bit of a mess she's trying
not to call attention to over there
no it's actually just that the camera
keeps shifting that way and then it
keeps like showing outside and i'd
prefer to do that um make sense i don't
know why it won't just i wish it could
just be forward but if i try and shift
it this way it'll just go whoop so i
feel like troy has unlocked an
interesting piece of information so the
nugget moves around your home
the nugget has in the night while she
sleeps it's not a static it's an
autonomous nugget
yeah i have no say in where it shows up
each morning
is that the question
i moved the next interesting uh why did
i move the nugget oh um i my dad's
coming to visit and i played well here's
my chicken nuggets no i put it in the
guest bedroom because i thought that he
was well you seem to be doing well
is that a chicken nugget in the floor
no dad
my dad is where he was
i didn't like that i didn't that wasn't
i wasn't a fan of that that's a spot-on
rendition of your dad he's very
australian i sometimes have to translate
he said he was gonna take me to dinner
when he was in town too by the way
my dad
absolutely you guys talk when the rest
of us
said this before he wouldn't even know
how to do dinner in l.a he the concept
would come no no he left it to me to
choose the restaurant oh then
yeah then then you have to do everything
make sure you get a good restaurant
sounds small kiwi but um i'm not going
to insult you your father is from new
zealand you should know this
i'm imagining he's more of a broden from
auntie donna is that more weird
how's it going he's like he's pretty
he's got high energy when he talks and
he
he does this little dad
oh that's awesome i asked him what a
t-shirt size was and he said m for
muscles
i love your doubt already [ __ ] yeah it's
good yeah yeah
take me to proms
and i was like does that mean medium and
he said no muscles
pieces [ __ ]
excited for him to visit um but i did
want to ask speaking of the news i
assume the answer this is going to be no
i haven't real chicken nugget
has anybody seen nope
i haven't yet no nearly so soon great
topics
didn't think so is it awesome is it
awesome is it up to the standard of the
because his stuff has been so good well
i think get out is
top 10 brilliant fantastic totally i
think it's okay
why is why is get out top 10 bright i
think the oh it's amazing you want an
oscar oh no i'm not saying that i'm
asking you why you think it is the the
way that that movie layers tension and
uh perfectly co-exists with comedy uh i
think is is
pretty unique in the way that they nail
that also like that exploration of that
particular theme is not something that
i've ever seen before
and i feel like they executed on it very
well he executed on it very well us i
found to be scary
but i
felt like the
theme
didn't really hold itself together as
well as i would have liked i know a lot
of people disagree with that but i
didn't i was going to say it was less
cohesive it didn't feel as
focused as it could be like you got to
ask questions type thing and sure um but
i think if you ask a few too many
questions and it falls apart
like how did they get the same clothes
like this just worth you know
worth calling out that both those films
are shot so beautifully yeah and looks
so like especially all the like mirror
fun house stuff yeah um in in us uh were
so vivid and and like amazing looking
and and of course
uh michael abel's a composer who jordan
peele found on youtube
wrote amazing scores for both of those
wow both of those movies and he's a
really really good dude he has spent his
whole career in the more academic side
of music he he wrote operas and he's
never done a film score until get out
wow and um
and it like immediately threw him into
the sort of upper echelon of damn a film
after that i'm not just the nicest
but um it's also it's also him that i
don't think abel's will ever let go of
him gotcha
um i liked it it's
uh
it's not horror and i think that the the
trailer
no and i think the trailer really [ __ ]
that up
um it makes you think it finds my heart
it's very sci-fi so it's a it's an
action-y
not really uh i guess sci-fi movie um i
found it extremely entertaining
it was always entertained it's one of
those movies where when i was watching
it it was all i was thinking about you
know i never strayed a thought but it
didn't leave me with anything either um
which i think is just maybe an
expectation that's on jordan peel now
which um isn't necessarily fair but i do
feel like the marketing was wrong so i
did really enjoy it but i'm like yeah it
was a good fun movie that's kind of it
do you think that that's that's a result
of the studio or do you think that's a
where do you think that comes from we
talked about marketing a lot especially
for this but
i my guess is that that's what they
think jordan peele's audience wants and
thus think that's how they have to sell
the film
um
and there's like
one two things in it that i would
consider to be horrific
um but it's definitely not a horror film
you're not scared
it's uh
it's what would you call alien
aliens are horror
we're back to this again
this is it it's more i think aliens more
of a romantic comedy
yeah
of unrequited love no it's thrilling
just what it looks like the whole tell
story right yeah hello my baby hello
outside i'm thinking spaceballs i would
recommend nope and i do have friends who
really really loved it um
yeah i was just like i was entertained
it was good
cool
cool the film is cool some really good
i felt similar i watched everything
everywhere all once recently and i was
like this is a really entertaining movie
like i remember a lot of people got
madly excited about it i thought it was
really good but similarly kind of yeah i
didn't what makes it the way it does for
everyone i think
what's incredible
that have you seen it no
without spoiling anything oh well i can
say this without spelling anything i
feel like that movie to me
so clearly executes on exactly what its
vision is while still being very funny
and very heartfelt that it it seems like
it hasn't been tampered with by any
execs anywhere at all to the extent that
it's a miracle that it got made because
it's so [ __ ] weird like it's a very
bizarre movie that that's core theme is
really be nice
like that's what the movie's about
really um and for that to be such a
simple message that's blown up into this
ridiculous film and to still fully
execute on that i was just blown away by
it interesting there there yeah there
are there are that's such a i totally
agree that's a really good description
of it the it felt like a movie that was
allowed to
pitch a very specific and hyper novel
hyper stylized
approach to a very otherwise simple
concept with no interference there's one
shot i remember where it's basically
just this
rapid fire montage of like 50 million
iterations of her face
and i remember thinking like just the
production design and makeup and also it
was like just to get that five-second
shot it was five vfx size i think or
something like some ridiculously small v
effects on that it's absolutely amazing
i might be it might have been 10 i might
be exaggerating but no i really enjoyed
it i think i just suffered from hearing
it's the best movie ever for like a
month before i also had that though and
lived up to it yeah
that movie i i
it's a shame i really think it's one of
the best movies ever made like i watched
it and i wanted to cry
just because i was so overwhelmed by
the cohesion i don't know my problem is
i cry at every movie so i never cried
for me oh my i weep i mean i yeah i weep
but like like bad movies as well
all i need is like a stick transformers
reward while someone looks moody
honestly i think i might have cried a
bumblebee i think
genuinely can i just question all the
other ones do you i mean we may have
talked about this before do you think
that you says one of the greatest movies
ever made yeah i don't think that it is
yeah and i'm not alone on that
filmmakers have said that about it too
right my i think we may have pretty much
the system of movies
perfect example so if it's
i got it
do you think that the greatest whatever
ages out
or do you think that it
i mean i still think that godfather is
one of the greatest that's what i was
going to say the godfather it doesn't
need jobs oh my god guys i watched the
show and it's inevitable
i
i just watched chinatown and i it was
one of those movies where i thought i've
seen this before and i was like i've
never seen this before
holy [ __ ] what what why did you think
that it was gonna be bad because i feel
like there's this weird undercurrent of
people there we're talking about the
offer we're talking about the offer
we're not talking about yeah i know um i
expected it to be bad because i'm at a
point where anything that's a spin-off
of something i expect to be bad
especially oh it's
it's definitely well it has to be hey
we're paramount and it's very like there
is definitely like a product placey vibe
to it
it was definitely made because paramount
had all the rights to that and realized
they could have their logo in fifty
percent of the show on the screen well
yeah and i wanted the merry street
it's awesome but it's definitely this is
a spicy take i just feel like the space
we're in right now with streaming
services competing with each other in
i don't want to say this across the
board because there are a lot of things
that i could argue against do with but
um has led to a lot of grabbing at ip in
order to make a series in order to make
people subscribe and uh not that much
consideration of quality
oh dude
let's let this assuage that fear the
quality of this that may be true but not
apply to this [ __ ] sure yeah yeah yeah
i'm not saying that's yeah but
specifically for this it didn't feel
that way at all we're coming we're 50
years of the movie and it's
worthy of oh my god what was that it's
worthy of uh
retreading that ground and there's still
as much as i know about that movie as
much as i know about the people that
were in charge of it and and i there's
stories that i'd never heard
it
it's about the making of the godfather
so it's so during the weekend it's from
the writing
we're definitely gonna redo the podcast
here but yeah it's really it's from the
the yeah it's from i mean it starts with
the novel of mario
starting the novel at through to the
release i was i was i kind of was in the
same place as you alana i was like i
don't
like i've i feel like i've seen that's
not the story of the godfather but i've
seen that kind of it felt it the from
the i think from the way it was marketed
in the way it was sold was very much
like entourage with a sepia filter that
was kind of what my view of what that
show was interesting and i expected it
to be about for some reason about when
the movie came out like the cultural
impact or whatever but i guess it goes
well and they touch on that i think it's
how the culture impacted it yeah and
also just the insanity that it is to
make a film it's so it's it's so
inspirational that's what i capture i
remember on the show i said i compared
it to um
uh get shorty the tv show get shorty
rather than film i said like is it like
get shorty i think you guys said no it's
not or whatever i thought for me it
clicked in exactly the same way as that
show did anyone who's watching this
who's not seen to get shortly tv show my
god no idea what that is
it's it's well we can come back to that
but yeah well no okay so get shorty was
a get shorty as a movie based on a book
it's uh what's his name i wrote some
jackie brown [ __ ]
[ __ ] his name is [ __ ]
right jackie brown tarantino did not
know the book it's based on the book
jacqueline is based on i can't remember
the name of the currency didn't write
jackie brown remember no well it's not
going to take a book one of you will
oracle it get shorty the the so get
shorty
it's a drone travolta movie and it's
about like gangsters trying to make
movies the tv show
what is literally what if breaking bad
meets entourage like that was genuinely
what i think the pitch was and that
sounds awful but it was very interesting
but the crucial thing and the reason
yeah the reason i like to get shorty was
at the time that was on on tv and i
don't know if they're doing another
series but like it was on for like three
seasons the time where that was airing
was the time that we were doing john
wick so myself and my my producer and
one of my best friends ben we were in
hollywood yeah he's awesome we were in
hollywood kind of like the chances
trying to do hollywood project and
that's what the entrepreneurship show
was about we know we were the gangsters
what's the you know what like can we do
this and and the great thing about
hollywood one
i would say the best thing about
hollywood is when you come in you can
kind of fake it till you make it and
you'll kind of there's a there is if
you're someone who can put yourself out
there and kind of get that job you can
get that job it's very it was just a
fascinating experience for the two of us
going through that and that's what i
think this show also clicks like that
first episode where it's like the guy
rocking in and just like deciding to be
in hollywood and faking it until he made
it that was definitely something that
resonates
very much with my experience of
especially with john wake up just like
walking into hollywood going i'm gonna
convince all these people that i should
make a game based on john wick and kind
of getting away with it and that was
it's only something it was a period in
my life which i even
i guess just did you watch it resonates
with that stuff did you watch the little
behind the scenes things that they would
park at the end of each episode oh gosh
every time they had already on there uh
who's you know now i don't believe 50 of
it to be clear like there's a lot of
stuff we've talked about
we've talked about i don't think it's
all true i don't think it's true well
there's there's certain things that he
solves every problem by being the clever
man in the room and it's written by him
i don't know if i believe it what do you
mean it's a good story already
it very much is a show that feels like
it was written by the protagonist it is
it's based on didn't i believe he wrote
a memoir that it is a direct adaptation
of and the guy
who um
you know the guy i'm forgetting his name
his last name is bart um but the the guy
who's part of uh bob evans crew
and yeah yeah yeah who who like there's
the scene where
uh he's talking about colin hanks
and colin hanks is like you know no to
this no that whatever i don't like it
and the guy's kind of going you should
know more about like that that guy the
one who was there kind of trying to
represent bob evans with him you know
sort of not in the room
i'm trying to be vague here
the um that guy is still around and i
did read an article from him
to your point mike where he goes
some of this is not quite how i remember
it for the record
yeah and that doesn't matter to be
honest half most of the best history is
made up like i'm cool with it like i'm
fine with it um it's a very entertaining
show like there's a lot of liberties
that they take where like um
yeah they play with the timeline don't
they they definitely push there's a
little bit of timeline but it's also i
think i think a lot of that's just to
facilitate it being like they have 10
storytelling a big story
and to be clear no no problem with it i
think it makes in either way
yeah on its face it's still just
something to enjoy whether or not the
the the tension for the entire show
comes from the fact of how close they
come to calling it quits
over and over and you're making the
godfather and what the problem is they
don't know they're making the godfather
so that's what's brilliant about it in
fairness is that like a concept i've
never thought of before you can make the
godfather and not know that you're
making the uh well they're actually
experiencing really well now most people
think most people think that they were
making though it was the it was going to
sink paramount it was the worst thing
you could ever do you could most of the
creatives right which yeah except for
two people never seen fiction
already they were like even there even
they're doubting it even they've got
like yeah so you very rarely do you see
in fiction
um create the creative process
demonstrators what it usually is which
is a bunch of people panicking that
they're what can i ask that any of you
of any of the things that you've ever
worked on
do you ever know that what you're
working on is good or how often do you
think what you're working on is good
i've noticed an inverse correlation
personally like if i really think
something's excellent then that's
usually not the thing
i've i've had both where i was like holy
[ __ ] i know that we're making something
great
um and also we're making something
that's talk [ __ ] i know and you were
right in both cases yeah and then i've
also i've i've had the whole thing
making something that's not going to be
good that's that ends up being great
which which humbles my opinion and helps
hone that going maybe your read is not
the best one um
and i've also had things where i think
that we're making something great that
ends up being bad
um but like the last of us we all knew
was like this is going to be awesome
yeah we know that we had no idea the
scope of its success
but we knew when we were from the very
time that i first heard the pitch it was
like holy [ __ ] a lot of that comes from
the pedigree of naughty dog
i mean
they had so many resources a great
creative team with
decades of experience behind them i knew
that this was gonna be the thing that
they were throwing their whole wonder
how they felt when they
made the first uncharted from the legacy
they had at that point in time to making
the last of us is very different you
imagine like even just going to the rich
meeting was such a bold same thing as
last of us they were like are you out of
your mind really
oh because i'd say that it's more of a
jump though right it was way bigger of a
jump it was never supposed to be a
franchise it was never called uncharted
it was called drake's
fortune i remember actually not long
after shipping yeah
doing i'm doing uncharted sorry also go
ahead i'm just a side comment no worries
go ahead
yeah i was just saying doing
uncharted
again after the legacy they had at that
point in time saying that
that to last of us is less of a jump
that makes sense i wonder what that
first uncharted pitch meeting
looked like it's interesting to find out
i i mean i know i can i can speak a
little to that uh because we did flo flo
was a ps3 launch title so we were
working on it in 2006
and
uh i remember
not long after came out what year was
uncharted was shortly 2007. yeah okay
yeah cause i was gonna say it a year
after the last 12 months yeah i remember
going up to
the bay area to meet clint bajakian
former
audio department star of lucasarts who
among other things wrote the score to
the awesome western first-person shooter
outlaws
uh from lucasarts heyday in the 90s
he was at the time working as one of the
senior level people in the sony music
department and it's essentially the guy
that hired me for
flow for my first
gig ever and a guy i will be essentially
forever grateful for to my dying breath
really lovely guy talented musician and
i remember i went up to just have a
meeting to kind of debrief i was like we
finished a game and you know to me it
was this gargantuan effort for them it
was like this is the smallest thing
we've ever made and they
he called me to his office and i always
told this story for years after
as a seminal difference between the film
and game industries because i've always
kind of bounced back and forth between
the two
um and
the
i remember going to his office in the
uh
former headquarter
in the bay area now they're in san mateo
but wherever they were before was closer
to the city and
he goes dude sit here i want you to try
this thing we're just about done with
and he put a controller in my hand and i
played uncharted in his office before i
think it was even announced
and his attitude was like what do you
think of this i think it's pretty cool
right it wasn't it wasn't
i'm gonna show you a revolutionary there
was no like grandstanding but it was
like this kind of cautious optimism and
again he's the audio department he's not
you know speaking on behalf of naughty
dog even it was just like
i i there was an enthusiasm so before we
even had our meeting for probably 30
minutes sat there just playing uncharted
and i said i can tell you i've never
shown up to meet like a director or a
filmmaker and they're like you want to
just like watch an episode of a show
before our meeting or like that's never
happened ever but we sat there and
played uncharted for a good 30 minutes
before
we chatted and and he seemed to think
this is gonna be good this is really
like
but not to the degree hesitance sees the
thing that hesitate like that's i think
that's i think a healthy
degree of kind of self-criticism
and criticism of the work again healthy
not like you know not to the point where
you're hating on yourself or you're
feeling bad about it but like
healthfully going i think this is good
but i'm just gonna do a bit more on it
to make it a little bit better the
reason i ask is because i have
absolutely no concept of what i'm
working on is good
and um like my brain can't i don't even
know and i think that maybe
this is probably not the correct
phrasing but you'll still get my point
that what i'm doing what i'm
i'm it's like i'm looking at it almost
more objectively i'm looking at it it's
like this piece goes here and this piece
goes here and this piece goes here and
then and then the pieces come together
and other pieces together how are the
pieces going oh this piece needs this
i'm looking at it there's a building
part of that
yeah that makes sense is it your first
big dev cycle as well so you haven't got
that experience necessarily so you've
not got that experience of seeing like
how those blocks kind of coalesce
towards the end like i think so that
knowledge sometimes people make that i
go that's [ __ ] cool but like
like yeah of the whole piece
i almost can't
i don't know if that will change when
it's out but i feel like i don't even
look at it
as
i can't make myself an audience member
i think you'll get better i think you'll
get better from experience at ex at
seeing the the potential like seeing
like you won't ever look at your work
and go this is great you will get better
i think as you well that should be your
warning cycles
yeah exactly
i've ever written i've never done that
i've only ever been like it's done and
that's good but i've never been like
it's great
or is yeah you'll not get there but i
think you might get a better
yeah i think that
i'm wondering if there's a conflation
between
will it be received as good or is it
inherently good and i think there's
nothing
about the reception at all and that's
been an interesting part of this process
is i don't think about the reception
whatsoever i just think about my job so
i think about this is what i need to get
done and here's how here's what i know
makes a quality thing and here's what i
need to do i never think about it
outside of i don't have the time to do
that i just have to be like i do my job
out of curiosity i but but if i may just
kind of circle back so like i'm i'm
trying to
compare this to like
we're in the middle of a scene and
we go through this scene we call cut
and everybody in the room goes holy [ __ ]
like you feel it you know that was the
take you know
everybody was operating on their a game
camera moved perfectly the beats were
hit
and then see what's happening
it's like the difference
troy the difference is time the
difference i don't have time to do that
but take imagine well no i was i would
say it's the duration imagine if doing a
shooting a take took three years
during those three years they do they're
working the scene when you're making it
happen like but you also constantly have
a holistic constantly have a deadline
there were scenes that we did i'll bring
this up and this is not being
disparaging to anyone on the team
nor or anything else but
when we were making avengers i was like
this is going to be [ __ ] awesome like
we're finally giving people the marvel
game that they want
the story that we had was incredible the
director that we had was incredible the
writing was incredible the actors were
[ __ ] incredible look at the team that
we had cost we had a great cast
so what i thought we were making was
going to be something that was like
we're making something that's going to
be clearly posited as games of service
using the mcu and the way that we always
do it's going to be there was going to
be the continuation from the cinematic
world into the games and now you get to
play iron man now you get to be all
these characters that's that's great
that's awesome
it's all about the execution but there's
scenes that we did there's scenes that
nolan and i had that were like [ __ ]
awesome like we all felt great about
that shauna skye our director is now at
naughty dog was like that's a great
scene so i understand what you're saying
as far as objectively looking back at
the entire project no you don't know but
i know that there's people that worked
on that game specifically that were like
this is [ __ ] cool we didn't we did
an amazing job using ms marvel we did an
incredible job of rethinking the
character of bruce banner and the hulk
and not just thinking of them as a
person versus just a machine or a device
i'd go as far as to say genuinely and
this this is good this is maybe a
controversial opinion here we go um this
is special
i'd go so far as to say good game bad
game to an extent doesn't matter to the
point which is the vast majority of p of
work of individual jobs that are done on
a game are done well
i would say
in terms of if you think of games as a
group of workers maybe it's magic
products of their work it's available
doing excellent work i would say the
vast majority of times where a game
doesn't work it's not because
individuals are producing bad work it's
about that work not coming together
which is honestly largely down to people
at my job um
so like i think there's i think that's
a i think that i think there's maybe um
uh
maybe that's a part of where you're
talking about alana in the sense of like
your work is good because you're a
professional and you're skilled and
you're talented and your job is to be
critical of your work up to the point
where it's done and then hand it in and
and move on to the next task so i would
say you're doing great troy's doing
great austin's doing great i'm doing
great hopefully the the thing that
defines whether a game is good or not
from a player point of view is the is
the meal rather than the ingredients
yeah
i'm not sorry insecure i don't think i'm
doing badly i just don't think about it
like it's you know you're i just keep
making things well you don't
and you don't have that necessarily you
don't have that view you don't have that
kind of satellite view of like what the
game is i just i just think about doing
my job that's all that's it that's it
get this done and i also think you're
happy too so that's all that matters no
for sure yeah i love my job
i mean a lot of gay like this is where i
i remember when journey came out that
game company rolled the credits with no
job titles everyone in the game was just
here's the alphabetical listing oh wow
that's interesting um
and
that was a deliberate choice to not to
to make it about the game
was a was a unit and if you liked it
everyone on this list is why you liked
it
um and despite the fact that like matt
nava was the art director you know
genova was the sort of creative
director team leader company director uh
you know robin hunnicky and kelly
santiago were the two uh executive
producers uh you know obviously i was
doing music chris bell started as like
an assistant and became one of the
designers you know and how did you feel
about being credited that way
well they did because technically i was
not an employee of that game company i
was credited as music by along with the
sony department people gotcha um but it
was the 12 or 13 that game company
actual employees
who were first credited you know well
before me
um
uh in their way and but if they had
chosen i would have felt quite honored
to be sort of folded into their ranks as
a symbolic gesture but of course i
understood why
contractually or on paper
uh it made sense to
to uh to probably brought in via sony
right rather than technically i was
hired by sony on that but yeah so that's
why i was curious the same kind of
question where
at what point do you know that something
that you're writing in terms of music is
good
because i think my thing is i look at it
so technically that i'm not ready to
think about it that way yet i think
that's what i'm doing and i i remember
when you were saying like they didn't
know they were making the godfather i
remembered a quote where leonard
bernstein became extremely famous and
his father had
discouraged him from pursuing the life
of a musician when he was younger
because he felt like his father came
from eastern european
jewish roots where you know he goes the
a musician is the is the destitute
violinist who plays at the wedding i
don't want that for my son that was the
attitude of bernstein's father and so
then his son became like the most famous
american musician basically
and um
and so one day they asked him you know
how do you feel now about the fact that
your son
is
you know has achieved so much and he
said well how was i supposed to know my
son was going to grow up to become
leonard bernstein
uh and i i thought that was a perfect
encapsulation of the you never know when
you're in it even despite the signs and
i can tell you in the case of journey
there were two things
that were kind of like noteworthy for me
i remember
the night before the reviews dropped
the game was done it had been done for a
couple months you know going through the
gold mastering process blah blah blah so
i'd been sitting on it and been able to
kind of process after all this work for
years
and i remember thinking
i played through the game one last time
before like on my dev kit and i go
i don't know if a single other person is
gonna like this game i genuinely cannot
i can't guess i can't because as soon as
i go oh yeah this is definitely gonna
land my mind will flood with things that
probably won't work or they'll go it's
pretentious it's a walking simulator
immediately all those things that are
gonna pull it down uh fled into my head
and the opposite would then also happen
where i go this is pretty [ __ ] like
like pretentious or whatever and then
and then all the things that are great
about it would start to flood in my head
so i just was going in circles and i
said here's all i know
whether or not other people like it
it does feel like
we made what we were trying to make
whether that resonates with people time
will tell whether reviewers like it
whether players like it whether there's
overlap there uh but it does feel like
we can't fall back on well we ran out of
time we ran out of this sony intervened
and messed with it was like nope sony
had our back everyone at that came
company bled everything they had into
the game i put everything i had into the
game nobody dropped the ball in terms of
just dedication and whether that was
going to add up to something other
people liked we didn't know but i felt
um i felt uncompromised and the one
little telltale sign that i had was
right technically going back a couple
months before that
uh
we i had been playing it in my studio my
dev kit was hooked into my my computer
system where i wrote the music so i had
these big nice studio monitors that i
was playing the game through and it
always sounded great especially as the
mix was getting closer closer to finish
the live orchestra was now added into
the game all that kind of stuff and the
steve johnson sound design was like
maximally polished and i remember always
thinking like man the mix on this game
is just really coming together this is
awesome and then i had this thought you
know i
i should play this on like super generic
consumer gear just to do one last check
so i took my dev kit home for the first
time in three years and plugged it into
i had a sony sony bravia tv and i
plugged it right in and routed it to
like the little speakers that are on the
tv itself so no frills
and i sat down and i was like
we were at the point where you're in the
bug fixing mode so you're not able to
make any major changes it's just like
here's a little tweak and for me it was
going to be audio levels or i found a
cue that didn't trigger for the right
way or whatever that kind of thing
and so
uh my then wife uh
who had been hearing about journey for
three years uh but had never really seen
it i said hey do you want to sit and
check out this game it's only about an
hour and a half to two hours i'm just
going to take notes on my laptop to send
last little
you know finicky things that i find
but you can finally see what i've been
talking about for literally three years
and so she sat on the couch next to me
when i did a complete top to bottom play
through and she was to my right and the
laptop was to my left so i kind of
forgot she was there and i kept just
turning over typing things to the left
go back to the game play through it i
was playing in a very meticulous way
finally end credits start to roll i
finished my last note and i was like oh
yeah i wonder what she thinks i turn
over and she
was swollen ugly crying
a complete a complete mess like it
wasn't like wipe a tear and go wow that
was really touching it it was like she
it was it was like
you know it's like schindler's list or
something she had this devastated
reaction and i hadn't hit send on the
email and so then i finished and i wrote
um something like
uh
based on what i've just witnessed we
might actually have something here wow
because i had never i couldn't
synthesize that reaction myself i was
too aware i was too busy looking for the
bugs and doing all the stuff that's
exactly what i'm testing this yeah if i
may and i'm gonna have to bounce shortly
after this um
a friend of mine is a great producer and
a dear friend wayne miller and i may
have shared this with you guys before
talked about the archetypes of the
creative process and he said does this
sound familiar if i have i talked about
this
you have the matter ten episodes dude i
don't [ __ ] know anymore right
um you have the you have the mad man is
this 110 are we live i don't know
is this a stream i was eating for our
episode well you vomited for a hundred
so that i got a but i'm gonna take a
[ __ ] on 120 so here we go
uh you have the madman the architect the
builder and the judge and he said the
madman's responsibility is to just have
the ideas as crazy as they are untether
just just go get him out
then the architect is the one who can
come up with the plan for those crazy
ideas and then the builder is the one
that actually executes that and then
finally you have the judge and the judge
is the one who can sit back and go hey
this is a good idea or not and the
the task the challenge is to not jump
between those four roles before its time
you know when you're working on a team
you can outsource those jobs so this
probably is i would assume alana has
someone whose role is to be the judge to
use your analogy and to be the kind of
external kind of um
feedback loop i mean i i know that like
as we've grown as a company my job has
been increasingly to
stop being the madman i started i
started by not being the builder now i'm
no longer the architect i'm just about
giving up the madman role like that's
that's something that as a company grows
you kind of you you you find different
people you find better madmen better
architects and better builders but you
still have to be the judge the game that
you're making is actually building the
studio i asked him paper what his
biggest piece of advice on video game
writing would be the other day and he
said uh own the studio
yeah he's right
that has been my go like genuinely my
goal
i've definitely said this like before
like 100 percent there is a direct
correlation between the majority of
writers in a company
sorry my god senior seniority of writers
in the dev team is the biggest predictor
to the quality of writing
like how much power you give the writers
like if you think about the you know the
naughty dogs santa monica studios tim
schafer's santa monica if there is
someone in the senior role who's a
writer their games are better written
like it's just because so often story
historically in games has been something
you outsource
or get some people to do at the end
it's a fix for [ __ ] that went wrong in
level design or whatever
the more the more power writers have in
the team the better the stories are and
yeah the the the ultimate cheat mode is
to is to own this like i'll work on that
table i'll work on that
as long as yeah
the lead writer is a skilled writer as
opposed to just having crocheted me on
this podcast what i'm saying is 210
episodes but there's a lot of people who
have just kind of been grandfathered in
a position they have seniority because
of time oh for sure yeah
they've got final draft as opposed to
people get you do creative director
roles without any of the creative
experience because they've been around
for a long time that's a that's a whole
mess
yeah and i will say that i'm sure i've
said this before but it drives me nuts
industry-wide of every different facet
of the industry that i've worked in is
people being promoted into manager
positions who are bad managers
my manager at sony is so good because
he's had training and it's like
wow none of the others ever had well
there's a lot of people that get
training at all yeah they often be i i
only got it when i moved into management
role before i had the company back when
i was a design manager at another studio
i had to i had to go to my bosses and be
like i'm [ __ ] at this can i have some
training creatives are not good
managers but they're not good managers
it's a whole other thing they can be if
you learn if you if you if you create
opportunities for them to be tours
it's also like
that
some companies have full-time managers
people whose job it is to manage people
who don't also do other [ __ ] uh which is
like
what a heaven
where we're just we're just starting to
bring in some leads that uh that do that
it's fascinating
you still consider yourself indie mike
you and your big growing team there's so
many reasons i feel like comfortable
using that word these days but yeah i
know it's um
it's cool it's a lot of responsibility
it's scary but yeah but congrats though
doing a great job thank you thank you oh
i appreciate it we are crucially writers
in charge i love how something about you
putting this thermos or whatever to your
mouth
really makes it clear you have to leave
do this guys guys i've got to go fill
this like i'll fill this thermometer
yeah anyway very funny
um i don't know this probably isn't a
110 we should do that live we'll figure
it out i don't know uh thanks for
watching what a hot minute should i
check
this is 109b that's what this is is it
109 i don't know
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah let me check
let me check i'll do it quick i probably
don't it's a sleep episode uh
okay we are 110 [ __ ]
all right now i know what to label it
well it's 09b 109b let's try and figure
out live next week if we can maybe we'll
figure it out um all right thank you for
watching everybody i'm a lot of peace
i'm a video game writer that's troy
baker who's a video game actor that's
mike pithel he's a video game director
and that's awesome trees the video game
guys we'll see you next week and i'll
figure it out if we can do it live
[Music]
you